with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you even get a
meet anthos stay tuned because here's
the rewind let's jump right into it this
session is about how anthos helps solve
three challenges that enterprises face
minimizing risk increasing innovation
and growing and retaining talented teams
minimizing risk often involves creating
and enforcing complex IT policy building
robust guardrails in your environments
and restricting where data can go and
what services can be used that's not the
fun part developers want to spend time
and energy delivering value to customers
and embracing new technologies for
example you may want to adopt a hybrid
cloud strategy by adding multiple cloud
platforms along with your existing
on-prem deployment each new environment
brings unique development challenges
security constraints and its own quirks
and idiosyncrasies the more differences
you add the greater the risk and those
comes to the rescue with a unified
platform that can run across clouds and
on Prem your team can focus on building
and operating applications instead of
learning the differences of each
environment anthos is built on industry
standard open-source technology so the
risk of lock-in is greatly minimized
anthos lets you manage and control these
different environments under a single
pane of glass and with Angela's config
management you can define enforce and
track policy across your hybrid
environments with the centralized git
repository
along with minimizing risk and those
lets you innovate faster with anthos
developers can write serosa applications
that run in Google Cloud on Prem and
even on other clouds by using cloud run
your teams can focus on delivering value
instead of wasting time with cluster
management and kubernetes primitives
anthos also makes it easy to enhance the
observability security and control of
containerized and non containers
applications with the is Tia powered
service mesh and and those migrated
helps to convert physical servers or VMs
directly into containers with
requiring additional steps complexity or
labor making it easy to containerize and
manage all of your workloads by bringing
together serverless service mesh and
migration technologies into one platform
and those empowers your teams to be more
innovative and productive finally
finding and retaining talent becomes
much easier because anthos is based on
industry standard open source
technologies that more and more
developers are interacting with every
day you can find experts in the
community who can start contributing on
day one instead of hiring a team to
create and maintain complex internal
infrastructure skills an alert on the
job are more easily transferable as well
allowing your teams to be more
collaborative and flexible if you'd like
to see the full talk check out the link
in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to cloud youtube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
[Music]